an educational side hustle a pandemic
themed holiday song there's a lot you
may not know about the tonight shows
Jimmy Fallon many comedians have dark
pasts that fuel their need for laughter
but Jimmy Fallon had it pretty well
Growing Up by all accounts the future
host of The Tonight Show was born in New
York City to happy Parents Gloria and
James Fallon as he'd later described
Vanity Fair his childhood was Picture
Perfect he elaborated my grandparents
were so happy everyone in the family was
funny and there was no divorce no
unemployment nevertheless like many
childhoods felons was full of rules his
parents were strict in terms of what he
was allowed to watch and where he was
allowed to go there was eventually an
exception to that rule however NBC
sketch comedy program Saturday Night
Live as a teenager Fallon became
obsessed with the show he would stay up
late every Saturday night to watch it a
tradition he continues now with his wife
and children aside from Saturday Night
Live Fallon was an avid listener of the
Dr Demento show which introduced the
world to comedy acts like Weird Al
Yankovic balance family was the perfect
audience for his own early attempts at
comedy including impressions of Dana
Harvey and Pee-wee Herman soon enough
Fallon would be on his way to becoming
an ambitious new face on the comedy
scene
before Jimmy Fallon was fully committed
to his future as a comedian his other
job prospects were influenced by other
aspects of his upbringing the fallons
were a family of devout Irish Catholics
which led a young Jimmy to consider
becoming a priest while many would feel
inclined to do this out of a deep
respect for their religion Fallon had
more of an interest in the pageantry of
the church which he became acquainted
with as an altar boy as Fallon later
recalled being an altar boy was his
first experience with being in front of
a crowd but eventually it became clear
he was desperate for a little more
validation he echoed this idea on Mike
birbiglias working it out podcast in
2022 mentioning that being a funny
priest seemed much easier than being a
funny comedian still Fallon's interest
in comedy eventually thrust him into the
much higher Stakes world of stand-up
Fallon performed stand-up comedy on the
side during his college Years often
taking the bus from the College of Saint
Rose and Albany to the famous Caroline's
comedy club in Times Square though his
early attempts at telling jokes trended
more towards Andy kaufman-esque stunts
he found a small amount of Success
Through Impressions which guided him
towards the next stage of his burgeoning
comedy career first up Mr John Travolta
she's like thanks for having me I swear
to God this is so sweet over here right
after dropping out of college in 1995
Jimmy Fallon moved to Los Angeles with
the goal of pursuing comedy full-time a
prospect many have tried but few have
successfully been able to do
nevertheless his ambition was noticed by
Hollywood professionals eventually
gaining him a manager and earning him
his first few dollars on stage he
enrolled in improv classes with the
Groundlings a historic comedy school
with alumni including Conan O'Brien Tyra
Banks and Dax Shepard it wasn't long
before Fallon started to sneak his way
into film and TV he landed his first TV
gig with a guest appearance as a
photographer in the second season of
ABC's Spin City a late 90s sitcom
staring Michael J fox and Richard kind
believe it or not balance casting on
Spin City may be owed to a certain
future Avenger during a 2023 episode of
The Tonight Show Fallon and Chris Evans
discussed the fact that around the time
that Fallon appeared on Spin City Evans
was an intern in the casting office did
I give him your first job
I mean this is I feel like I own my
whole career to you
still performing on SNL would remain
Fallon's white whale for years to come
Jimmy Fallon's determination to be a
cast member on Saturday Night Live
didn't Wane during his time in Los
Angeles and his opportunity to audition
finally came when he was just 21 years
old he didn't impress the show's
producers enough to earn a spot on the
cast or as a writer and for a moment
phelan's childhood dream seemed crushed
While others would have taken this loss
as the end of their Journey Fallon kept
his chin up over the next two years he
accrued more experience in TV roles
including a pilot for the WB Network
Fallon was deadly serious about his
Ambitions he recounted to Rolling Stone
I remember saying to myself if I don't
make it on Saturday Night Live before
I'm 25 I'm going to kill myself
fortunately things didn't come to that
as Fallon got a second chance to
audition in 1997. his winning bit was a
parade of celebrity Impressions which
included Jerry Seinfeld Chris Rock and
Adam Sandler which pulled a rare laugh
from SNL producer Lauren Michaels so I
was like I was like yeah my mom wants me
to go on this walk at the island
yeah
Fallon joined the cast of season 24 in
1998. after his audition Saturday Night
Live head writer Tina Fey testified that
Fallon was truly prepared to be a part
of the cast Faye recalled Fallon's
audition to Vanity Fair saying he's one
of two people I've ever seen who was
completely ready to be on the show
luckily FaZe hunch proved correct as
Fallon quickly won over audiences with
the same Adam Sandler impression that
won over Lauren Michaels seemingly
overnight Jimmy Fallon went from
struggling stand-up comic to the latest
SNL star he appeared in recurring
sketches like the Boston teens with
Rachel Dratch and had many amusing
instances of breaking character and
cracking up with fellow cast member
Horatio Sans Fallon famously broke
during the iconic more cowbell sketch as
well as one disastrous addition of
Debbie Downer at Disney World
all right
balance escapades partially with Sans
weren't just limited to their on-air
hijinks notably the two took full
advantage of Saturday night Live's
culture of partying and alcohol staying
out into the early hours of the morning
drinking and getting into occasional bar
fights Sans later recounted to vulture
we definitely fed into the fact that
being out of control is good on that
show
Saturday Night Live quickly increased
Jimmy Fallon's celebrity profile as the
comedian was upgraded from featured
player to main cast member after only
one season Fallon later gained even more
notoriety when he began co-hosting
Weekend Update alongside Tina Fey during
his third season on the show around the
same time Fallon played a minor role in
Cameron Crowe's 2000 film Almost Famous
as promotional manager Dennis hope
eventually Fallon ended up being chosen
to host various award shows for MTV over
the years including the MTV Movie Awards
and the Video Music Awards while hosting
the former in 2005 Fallon first
encountered a trio of writers and sketch
comedians known as The Lonely Island
consisting of Andy Samberg Akiva Shafer
and yorma Tacony their unique sense of
humor caught Fallon's attention Fallon
ended up recommending the Trio's online
content the producers of Saturday Night
Live and before long Warren Michaels
invited them to audition Sandberg joined
the show as a cast member with yorma and
Akiva as writer and the three completely
changed SNL for the digital age even
after each of them moved on from the
show the members of The Lonely Island
have appeared on The Tonight Show on
occasion Jimmy Fallon eventually
departed from Saturday Night Live
Following Season 29 in 2004 after which
he was replaced as Tina Fey's Weekend
Update co-anchor by Amy pohler
fortunately the future looked right for
Fallon as he had just starred in his
first lead film role alongside Queen
Latifah in taxi however the film ended
up doing poorly at the box office when
it was released that same year despite
felon's performance Charming summer
viewers Fallon's second chance came with
a role he seemed better suited for in
the 2005 romantic comedy fever pitch
opposite Drew Barrymore the film centers
on the romance between Fallon's
character a devout Boston Red Sox
fanatic and Barrymore's a workaholic who
doesn't understand his obsession however
fever pitch also saw a lackluster return
at the box office while reviews from
critics and viewers were also generally
lukewarm are you saying that she's out
of my league
she's bringing some serious heat man I
don't know if you got the best speed oh
I got the bad speed following the
failure of fever pitch Fallon hit a
surprising dead end in his career once
film offers stopped rolling in Fallon
decided to move back to New York City
eventually hitting a depressive period
with no real insight on how he'd go
forward however all he ended up having
to do was wait for an old Mentor to come
knocking with the opportunity of a
lifetime even though it left his career
at a standstill Fallon has a lot to
think fever pitch for through his work
on the film he ended up falling in love
with Nancy Juvonen the co-founder of
Drew Barrymore's production company
flower films Fallon and Juvonen later
recounted the specifics of their first
introduction to each other during an
episode of The Tonight Show at home
edition when he produced episodes of the
show with his family during the initial
covid-19 lockdowns in 2020 on a walk
outside their home javonen recounted how
they first met at Saturday Night Live
when Barrymore was hosting and Fallon
eagerly introduced himself to her
javonin added that she later developed a
crush on Fallon on the set of fever
pitch after a produced or brought their
kids to set and she noticed him playing
with them so I think that's when my
heart just sort of
melted even more
I remember those kids oh they're so cute
yeah
the two got married in 2007 and
currently live in New York with their
two daughters were born in 2013 and 2014
Fallon's wedding to jeffonin wasn't
without hijinks as one would expect from
a comedian's wedding as he later
recounted on the Drew Barrymore show in
2020 his wedding was crashed by none
other than Kermit the Frog after the
videographer heard their wedding song
would be the Rainbow Connection although
it was a perfect wedding regardless
Kermit made it into every shot of the
wedding video
following Jimmy Fallon's career slump
after his failure in the world of movies
Lorne Michaels made good on a promise he
made to Fallon shortly before the
comedian left Saturday Night Live at the
time Michaels and Tina Fey both
suggested that Fallon could be a good
replacement for Conan O'Brien on late
night when he eventually took over The
Tonight Show from Jay Leno however
Michaels probably didn't expect that
recommending Fallon for the job in 2007
would result in conflict with NBC
Executives as Fallon later told GQ NBC
was like this is going to flop this is
going to be like Chevy Chase's show
Michaels remained supportive of Fallon
despite the comedian's failure as a film
star nevertheless those Executives were
proven right when Late Night with Jimmy
Fallon debuted in 2009 as some critics
considered the host a step down from
Conan however Fallon slowly began to win
over audiences especially as public
behind the scenes turmoil Hit The
Tonight Show with Conan O'Brien the
relatively drama-free Late Night with
Jimmy Fallon became a sanctuary for
upbeat positive comedy Fallon success on
late night TV was inevitably all thanks
to Lauren's confidence as he had become
a mentor figure for the comedian during
his six years of SNL fortunately Fallon
lucked out with perhaps the best house
band in all of late night the roots who
made the show something truly worth
watching Fallon taped late night at 30
Rockefeller Center where he continued
his talk show tenure after inheriting
The Tonight Show from Jay Leno in 2014.
this also kept him in close proximity to
Saturday Night Live where he has
returned to host three times so far over
the years the comedian also made an
appearance alongside Justin Timberlake
in the sketch series 40th anniversary
special in 2015 which gathered a who's
who of Hollywood icons to celebrate the
show with reunion sketches tributes and
musical performances the most memorable
part of the night however took place
after the camera stopped rolling the
cast crew and audience of SNL 40
gathered at the Plaza Hotel for what
would become the most legendary after
party in the history of Saturday Night
Live 5. Fallon recounted the event the
next night on The Tonight Show revealing
that there was no scheduled musical
performer with the party instead
arranged to have an empty stage in
instruments for anyone to jam after
unintentionally accepting duties as the
party's MC Fallon roped in all sorts of
musical performers Taylor Swift Paul
McCartney and Michael Bolton all played
their hits but the true highlight of the
night came when Prince played Let's Go
Crazy to a star-struck audience of
a-listers while his tenure on The
Tonight Show has mostly been a good time
Jimmy Fallon also had to host while
dealing with tragedy in his personal
life in 2017 the talk show host canceled
a week of shows when his mother Gloria
suddenly passed away and his first
episode back was a roller coaster of
emotions she would squeeze my hand three
times and say I love you and I would
squeeze back I love you too Taylor Swift
was in town to perform on Saturday Night
Live and she agreed to be the musical
guest at the last minute in support of
Fallon the moment was made even more
special when Swift came on to perform
the ballad New Year's Day offered 2017
album reputation which contains the line
you squeeze my hands three times in the
back of the taxi in a Twitter thread
posted shortly after the episode The
Tonight Show Producer Mike dicenzo
revealed that since the album had just
been released days earlier everyone was
shocked to hear the line that paralleled
Fallon's story The Host ended up in
tears and when the song ended he gave
Swift a heartfelt embrace the song's
producer Jack Antonoff a friend of
Fallon and frequent collaborator of
Swift also tweeted praise for the
performance and moment the next day the
covid-19 pandemic derailed many things
including the world of late night TV
Jimmy Fallon embraced his time in
quarantine by filming episodes of The
Tonight Show in his home with the help
of his family which made for a Charming
escape from the Grim state of the war
World however as the pandemic continued
into 2021 Fallon decided he wanted to do
a little more to help people escape
their struggles recorded at New York
City's Electric Lady Studios Fallon
released a collaboration with Ariana
Grande and Megan B stallion titled it
was a masked Christmas Fallon described
his intent behind the song to The
Associated Press saying I wanted to
write something reflecting on how tough
it was for everyone last year during the
holidays and that it's gonna get better
the song covers relatable topics such as
getting booster vaccines staying masked
in public and participating in family
Zoom sessions it was a masked Christmas
is only the most recent in a long
history of Christmas themed singles from
Fallon in the past he duetted with the
legendary Dolly Parton for a cover of
Mariah Carey's all I want for Christmas
is you and he also performed Paul
McCartney's iconic wonderful Christmas
time with the former Beatle the roots
and the cast of sing back in 2016.
however this 2021 tune was his first
original Chris Christmas classic aside
from hosting the Tonight Show since 2014
Jimmy Fallon has also made a career for
himself as an author of children's books
this journey started for Fallon in 2015
when he was inspired by recent
fatherhood to write your baby's first
word will be Dada in an interview with
NPR Fallon described the book's premise
as an act of selfishness explaining how
he tried to trick his daughter into
saying the word Dada he joked I would
call everything in the house Dada Fallon
continued to regularly release
children's books over the years all
inspired by his experiences as a parent
he even channeled his love for Christmas
into a 2020 book titled five more sleeps
till Christmas however his most
adventurous experience came in 2022 when
he collaborated with none other than
Jennifer Lopez on a children's book
titled con Poyo a bilingual playtime
Adventure this team effort aims to teach
kids Spanish with the help of a lovable
chicken Amigo eating chicken no you're
not eating the chicken in this this
you're friends with the chicken frenzied
the chicken no one eats the chicken
though the team up between Fallon and
Lopez may seem random it was something
they both had wanted to do for a long
time Fallon told people that approaching
Lopez to write the book with him was
inspired by his respect for her as a
mother saying one of the many things I
love about her is how great of a mom she
is what started for Fallon as a way to
channel his parenting anxieties has now
become a successful side Venture for the
comic by 2023 Jimmy Fallon had
accomplished a lot in his career much of
which he probably never anticipated when
he was just a struggling actor while the
comedian has plenty to look forward to
in his future one bucket list item for
him has recently been crossed off in
2022 Fallon invited Cameron Crowe onto
the Tonight Show to promote a Broadway
adaptation of his movie Almost Famous
which Fallon appeared in over 20 years
earlier on the show Crowe personally
invited Fallon to reprise his role as
Dennis Hope on stage at some point
before Almost Famous closed in January
2023 which Fallon accepted sadly Fallon
never made good on his promise to Crow
but he did make a special appearance
during one of the last nights of the
musicals run on Broadway after attending
her performance with lin-manuel Miranda
and Crow Fallon was pulled on stage by
one of the cast members during their
ending vows which was met with roaring
Applause from the audience it's clear
that Fallon has come a long way from
where his career was at the turn of the
century and that he won't be going
anywhere anytime soon
[Music]